[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on est là ce soir pour parler du
transport de demain
hyper louf et comment avec un minimum
d'ambition politique industrielle et
financière on peut mettre limoges à 35
minutes de paris à horizon 2025 2030
alors attendez on n'est pas en train de
parler du dernier roman de science
fiction
on est en train de parler d'une rupture
technologique actuellement en train de
se passer
ou devrais-je et du changement majeur
dans le futur de nos habitudes de
déplacement quand je dis que c'est un
concept qui datent pas d'aujourd'hui
les premiers principe avait été décidé
ou commencé à être étudié lors des
premières lignes du métro de new york
donc on parle d'un concept qui a plus de
100 ans c'est clairement quelque chose
qui n'est pas nouveau et quelque chose
qui est à notre portée de main
aujourd'hui j'ai pris le train pour
venir à limoges il ya quelques jours
ça m'a pris quatre heures
alors je me suis dit on va trop de
bosses et on a fait travailler un petit
peu malheureusement le réseau
téléphonique était pas exceptionnel
paris sia travail aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance enfin j'ai la chance oui depuis
quelques mois je suis originaire de
bretagne et on a une ligne à grande
vitesse pour à peu près la même distance
que paris limoges
donc on fait par irène en une heure et
demie comment aujourd'hui vous pouvez
accepter d'avoir limoges à quatre heures
de paris
on est au delà du désenclavement des
territoires
on est dans l'implication de la france à
travers limoges dans le développement
technologique du transport de demain
on est dans l'implication de limoges au
niveau européen au niveau mondial en
collaboration avec le canada et l'italie
on a une chance inouïe
demain de pouvoir écrire le futur et je
vais vous l'expliquer dans quelques
instants qu'il est très très très simple
alors avant de commencer et de rentrer
dans les détails on aurait fait on a
fait un petit exercice avec l'équipe et
on a calculé qu'elle pouvait être
l'impact économique pour la région si
demain on était capable de se déplacer
en 35 minutes de limoges à paris
aujourd'hui on va faire un petit peu de
matches donc je sais que c'est la fin de
la soirée mais suivait c'est pas très
compliqué mais vous êtes j'espère que
tout le monde à comprendre
donc aujourd'hui on a vingt mille
véhicules jour qui font le trajet entre
limoges et paris
si demain on est capable de faire le
même trajet en 30 minutes
ça nous fait un gain de temps à peu près
de trois heures sur la durée totale du
trajet avec un gain de 3 heures
multipliez ramener donc au nombre total
de véhicules dont vous me suivez
trois heures de gains vingt mille
véhicules
ça nous fait deux fois 3 6 60 me leur
potentiel de gagner par jour ce qui est
ni plus ni moins équivalent à 7 ans par
jour enghien alors après je vais être
honnête avec vous tout le monde ne va
pas prendre hyper look du jour au
lendemain donc la 7e calcul on part sur
l'hypothèse que 100 % des voyageurs
demain vont voyager avec ça mais même si
on ne prend que vingt pour cent
du trafic qui existe aujourd'hui sur
l'a20 ça nous ramène à un an et demi
heure potentiellement productives pour
la région donc vous l'aurez compris
aller vite a quand même un certain
avantage
alors maintenant comment ça marche quand
je vous dis qu'on n'est pas sur la
science fiction c'est essentiellement
parce que on réutilise des technologies
existantes qui arrivent soit de
l'aéronautique soit du ferroviaire soit
du spatial l'infrastructure de notre
côté on la veut la plus basique possible
on au conte et sur des tubes en métal de
4 mètres de diamètre qui aujourd'hui
sont très bien connus ou c'est quelque
chose de produits par l'industrie
éolienne sur des poteaux en béton où ça
peut être également enterrées ou
semi-enterrées en fonction de la
géographie la ligne vous l'aurez compris
s'il faut traverser les alpes on va pas
s'amuser à faire un truc sur des poteaux
va falloir creuser ensuite ces tubes
sont connectés à des pompes à vide ces
pompes à vide
aujourd'hui ce sont des allemands qui
sont leaders sur le marché
elles sont disponibles elles sont sur
catalogue vous pouvez les acheter demain
on connecte ses tubes avec des pompes à
vide
grâce à ces pompes à vide vous réduisez
la pression a jusqu'à 90% à l'intérieur
du tube donc vous êtes quasiment en
haute atmosphère c'est comme si vous
vouliez à 50 km d'altitude et grâce à ça
vous affranchissez des frottements
aérodynamique et vous pouvez atteindre
des vitesses qui sont similaires voire
supérieure à celle de l'avion donc on
est sur une infrastructure que l'on veut
le plus basique possible pour pouvoir
maximiser la pertinence économique du
système et avoir un coût au kilomètre
qui soit inférieur à celui d'une ligne à
grande vitesse
alors maintenant les véhicules donc on a
des capsules qui font 25 m de long 1 qui
voyagent à 80 secondes d'intervalle
alors je vois ici la réaction
vingt secondes d'intervalle mais le mec
est complètement malade aujourd'hui la
sncf travaille sur des tgv autonome avec
des intervalles à 100 secondes entre
deux entre deux entre deux trains à
l'horizon 2023
donc quand on parle de 80 secondes entre
deux potes ou deux capsules
on est clairement sur les même ordre de
grandeur ensuite quand on parle de
réutiliser des techno existantes
le fuselage ou la capsule est identique
ou quasiment identiques un fuselage
d'avion on est avec des cabines
pressurisées comme dans les avions et le
tout fonctionne au niveau de la
lévitation et la propulsion avec des
systèmes électro magnétiques qui sont
aujourd'hui connus ou similaire que la
ligne que l'on a
y'en a qu'une seule aujourd'hui dans le
monde entre l'aéroport de shanghai et le
centre-ville de shanghai
donc on réutilise tout ça et on intègre
et c'est le défi aujourd'hui industriel
tout c'est toutes ces technologies
ensemble on apporte également un soin
particulier à l'expérience passagers de
la gare pour avoir des concepts de gars
qui soit agréable avec des zones
d'embarquement similaire à ce qu'on a
dans les avions
ce qu'on va avoir malheureusement et
j'espère qu'on pourra réduire ces temps
de l'armée des temps de sécurité pour
contrôler tout le monde on aura des
billetteries et l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir proposer aux voyageurs
la fréquence du métro avec la vitesse de
l'avion
c'est à dire que vous avez pas besoin de
réserver votre billet trois semaines
avant sous trois mois al avance pour
aller faire votre trajet
à l'autre bout de l'europe vous pointez
à la station vous prenez votre ticket de
métro
vous prenez votre ticket com votre
ticket de métro vous embarquer et 35
minutes après vous êtes à paris
donc c'est vraiment une révolution et on
n'est pas sûr avoir un maximum de
capacité à tout prix mais plutôt un
maximum de fréquences pour pouvoir
faciliter la vie des usagers de demain
ensuite sur l'intérieur j'ai cofondé la
société avec un cadre brillant de
l'université de toronto qui s'appelle
ryan johansen et ce monsieur que
d'ailleurs bryant a une qualité énorme
il est malade dans les transports il est
malade dans les transports et je peux
vous assurer qu'il attache une
importance toute particulière au confort
des passagers dans le design complet du
système
donc on est avec un nouveau mode de
transport qui se veut plus facile à
utiliser plus sur ce qu'on est protégé
par le tube des aléas climatiques moins
cher et respecter l'environnement
on est sur 100 % électrique là dessus
alors on va rêver un petit peu et on va
se projeter en 2050 et on va c'est
d'imaginer
la journée typique de fabien donc fabien
il a limogé jeudi ouais c'est quoi ta
journée aujourd'hui c'est olivier qui
lui demandent des dib écoute faut que
j'aille voir les catalans à barcelone
parce qu'en 2050 donc la catalogne et
indépendante
et puis après oui et puis j'ai les
russes qui m'ont collé un rendez-vous à
moscou donc on est en train de
cartographier c'est comme si vous aviez
la carte du métro parisien à l'échelle
de l'europe et ensuite après ton rendez
vous à moscou qu'est ce que tu fais oui
il faut que je repasse par londres etc
et puis on va essayer de rentrer j'ai un
truc à paris je vais voir si je peux y
assister mais je suis pas sûr donc
aujourd'hui on a une opportunité unique
de développer le moyen de transport de
demain avec des technologies existantes
on a cette opportunité
comment dirais-je d'intégrer un niveau
de collaboration entre deux parties du
monde
je le répète entre le canada et l'europe
donc donnons nous les moyens de nos
ambitions et demain on sera capable
d'aller voir un match du csp à paris est
rentré le soir même chez soi sur ce
merci bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]